on a platform in a station in Berlin a
group have come to look at a locomotive
but these are no ordinary train spotters
and this is no ordinary train it runs
not on electricity or diesel but
hydrogen
it is a glimpse of the future
it turns out we've already glimpsed
before because hydrogen has been the
fuel to save the world ever since the
19th century
in the 30s the 50s the 70s we were told
hydrogen cars and planes weren't just
science fiction they were just around
the next page
and so here we go again
he's coming we will leave soon thank you
we're already behind the schedule but
what if it is real what if this time it
isn't just sci-fi it would change
everything
thank you
this is the Vaseline refinery in Cologne
here in the rhinelands the heart of
Europe's steel chemicals and
Manufacturing industry this is where it
all begins where they turn crude oil
into petrol diesel jet fuel and the
ingredients for Plastics petrochemicals
fertilizers and pretty much everything
else you can think of the main product
we're making here is really we call it
the middle distillate so this is
basically diesel for transportation it
is heating oil it's quite important it's
also jet fuel to fuel the main Frankfurt
airport or the cologne airport for
instance
another element is the chemical industry
so 40 of our output goes into the
chemical industry as if that single
thing crude oil there's a lot of
different things that come from that
exactly now you're probably asking
yourself why in a report about green
energy we're here in a dirty oil
refinery well partly it's because some
hydrogen isn't very clean in fact
there's a whole Spectrum from Gray
hydrogen the stuff they make in places
like this from oil and gas to Blue
hydrogen where you capture the CO2
coming out of these chimneys to the Holy
Grail green hydrogen produced without
any emissions which brings us to this
seemingly unremarkable new Warehouse
we've got the demineralized water plants
so the water treatment uh isn't and it's
actually being poured into the uh into
the facility and then lined up here next
to each other a nice nice little blocks
are the electrolyzer stacks so water
goes in goes to the electrolyzers and
then it comes out as high to hydrogen
comes out one end and oxygen pops up out
the other so it starts with water it all
starts with water you see what you've
got here is one of Europe's biggest
green hydrogen projects creating the
element not from fossil fuels but from
Renewable Power they'll pipe the gas
back into the refinery where it can
carry on doing what it already does
but this is just the tip of the iceberg
because where hydrogen gets really
interesting is in its other quality as a
fuel the things that really make
hydrogen special are the fact that it
burns clean you don't have point of burn
CO2 emissions and that's huge right
especially if you're looking at
distributed applications where it's hard
to capture individually so that's one of
the big important things another one is
that it is storable you know we can
store it we can store it indefinitely it
can provide that seasonal flexibility
that long duration that we're looking
for in a lot of different sectors
hydrogen in other words isn't just about
trains and flying cars it might just be
the answer to one of the biggest
questions in the energy transition
however many wind turbines and solar
panels we have we will need a way of
storing vast amounts of energy for when
the wind's not blowing and the sun's not
shining the task battery is probably
can't fulfill
I think the biggest role hydrogen will
play is that intermittency and that
storage and kind of the use for all of
those parts of the energy system that
you can't Electrify easily the the high
grade heat that the bits around long
distance Mobility because you cannot
envisage a world where all of that is
done with electrons so so so so in a
sense actually hydrogen might be the
kind of invisible bits you know in 2015
2060 hydrogen you may not necessarily
have a hydrogen car perhaps you might
but you may not necessarily have a
hydrogen cut but hydrogen will be there
potentially as the backbone of the power
system and for the big trucks you can't
you know driving yourself exactly it is
part of the answer but it's not a silver
bullet and this is the other critical
thing you need to know about hydrogen
there's a lot of people spending a lot
of money right now trying to persuade
you that this gas H2 is the answer to
everything hydrogen in your boiler
powering your car in Planes but actually
quite a lot of this is hype I think
there are areas where hydrogen is not
needed and there's area areas where it's
apps
apps and then you come to the areas
where the jury is still
up and we just don't know because there
are a lot of Technologies and we're
really in day one or two of figuring out
what's going on those are things like
power generation potential aviation fuel
there's a lot of competing Technologies
as well
here on the banks of the river mersey is
a place you probably haven't heard of
before but without what they do here we
all be in big trouble
in this cavernous room are machines
which consume more power than the city
of Liverpool carrying out a task which
doesn't just matter for hydrogen but for
well everything
this is one of the most important
industrial sites in the country and it's
the first time anyone has been allowed
in to film this place why well let me
give you a sense of what they do here
they take brine concentrated salt water
and split it into a number of chemicals
including chlorine what's coming out of
those pipes there is what we use to
purify 98 of the drinking water in this
country if this place goes down then
within seven days we're rationing water
okay so I've probably got your attention
but why are we really here well guess
what's coming out of these electrolysis
cells as well as chlorine that's right
hydrogen wow okay and it's it's
literally this is a electrolysis
happening right now yes this is called
electrolysis uh and when we think about
making hydrogen we could actually
electrolyze water to make hydrogen and
there were no other uh contaminants or
or byproducts come from that other than
oxygen and water vapor using pretty much
the same machines very similar machines
to what we're doing here yes wow very
similar technology so it's a hundred
Euro technology but it's also possibly
the future absolutely
and innovine the company here says you
can repurpose its electrolyzers to make
green hydrogen it is one of many
companies hoping to make a killing in
the new hydrogen economy I say economies
Some people prefer to call it a bubble
they're not the first such bubble
the license plate tells the story H2 for
hydrogen back in the teeth of the 1970s
oil price shock Hollywood stars were
already getting in on the craze this car
driven by actor Jack Nicholson is not an
ordinary automobile it's a hydrogen car
it's fueled by hydrogen that has been
extracted from Water by pure sunlight
there are a lot of very good things that
could come from using the power of the
Sun
oh what about the early 2000s when the
second Gulf War prompted another look at
this technology
we can change our dependence upon
foreign sources of energy
we can help with the quality of the air
bubble after bubble ended with a pop the
cars and plants too expensive the
engineering too challenging the hydrogen
molecule to small and volatile to
control and most of all the markets just
not there
but might this time be different after
all this time governments have actually
committed to Net Zero and it's hard to
get there without something like
hydrogen for power for chemicals and
maybe for other things too
which brings us back to the railway and
a record-breaking hydrogen train which
just traveled more than a thousand
kilometers on a single tank
[Music]
the train certainly an experience even
if it might go over most people's heads
now if this were a regular commuter
train you would be hearing the sound of
diesel but instead it's basically silent
because
this is running on a fuel cell above
here above my head right now is a fuel
cell that's converting hydrogen from a
tank into the power that is running this
train it is an entirely New Concept and
we didn't have anything like this in the
UK yet at least
that's why we're here in Berlin rather
than Bridge end because we're still a
long way from investing as much as the
Germans I mean my personal view is
definitely coming it's definitely coming
I think it's a question now of when not
if it's the timing and for that for that
timing to work a number of items need to
be in place the government will play an
incredibly important role in this
because the development of that wider
economy
has a large political element to it as
well
so they are waiting for the governments
to build the pipes and infrastructure to
make it happen and for the time being
those Keen to see hydrogen in action are
coming to Germany rather than the UK for
this glimpse of the future
government officials from around the
world here for a test drive before they
snap up one of these trains what do you
say to all those people who say there's
been a lot of hype like for you know for
decades about hydrogen and what makes
this moment real we're on a hydrogen
train that's what makes it real you know
like
um you can South Australian government's
got over 500 million of investment in
hydrogen so we're very very serious
but if everyone's so serious does this
mean this isn't a bubble is it enough to
override continued worries about the
safety of this highly explosive gas and
what about cost up until recently blue
hydrogen the kind you get from fossil
fuels while capturing the CO2 was Far
cheaper than truly green hydrogen but
that's changed too we're finding that in
Europe
a green hydrogen project would be
cheaper than a new blue hydrogen project
today in parts of the market and
depending on your renewable electricity
design and that's a flip that's the
change compared with where we were even
you know kind of a year or so ago is it
it's mind-boggling so green hydrogen
right now is potentially cheaper than
blue hydrogen
but of those the UK has kind of got its
eggs in the blue hydrogen basket more
than the green hydrogen basket
the UK is definitely definitely sees a
larger wall for green in the future now
than it did before so originally the UK
had a target for hydrogen that was kind
of agnostic on color entirely now it's
doubled that Target and added a carve
out for green
as the next chapter of this story plays
out there are big questions for the
British government they were far more
focused on Blue hydrogen than most of
their neighbors they had lots of plans
for investment but now amid the chaos in
Westminster no one's sure what the
strategy is anymore
as another page in the hydrogen epic
gets written there's a chance this
country which once hoped to be the world
leader they get left behind again